sean can you tell us about the day that
you told your parents that you were
moving to los angeles and what were the
emotions that were going through you at
that time um
so yeah that's interesting because
i had been talking about moving to
southern california for a while
and i had a very close friend of mine
who we had similar dreams similar
aspirations and actually in a lot of
ways
it was him pushing me
to
follow my dreams and chase my dreams his
name is josh taylor
and
he
was a
incredibly gifted actor
comedian
also musician singer the whole nine he
was just one of those people that
anything he put his energy into
uh he excelled and we had a
english class together in uh
junior high i think is where it first
started and that teacher mr young was
his name was amazing he would give josh
like 10 minutes at the end of class to
basically do a stand-up routine and he
really recognized that energy and josh
pulled me into being a part of it and so
that's kind of how i started um really
kind of thinking about it
past you know i i grew up in the theater
with my father being a drummer professor
all that so i was in the theater world i
was very comfortable but this kind of
going up just almost stand up in a way
improv
was was a little bit newer to me at the
time but he kind of really pushed me and
so over the years our kind of dream of
moving to
southern california los angeles pursuing
the dream of being actors really at that
time
and
what ended up happening is
he decided he couldn't go
and so i was kind of left last minute
you know
going do i go or do i you know
by myself
and uh
my parents have always been super
supportive and they knew for years and
years uh i don't remember the exact
moment i told them i was going to move
down there but it was just kind of
common knowledge uh
in my hometown i was
directing commercials and acting in them
uh sent from like 16 years to like 20
years old i'd probably done like 30
commercials and
so
uh the kind of creative endeavors were
always supported by both my my mom and
dad they they thought it was amazing
they loved it and they said you know you
should you should pursue this so uh
just always support from them there was
never like any pushback or anything like
that and so it was just a matter of when
i was gonna go you know and i also did
some live performance stuff uh
and uh
i made it onto the news several times
just for those kinds of things and
again
even in those conversations it was so
what are you gonna do where do you see
yourself in the next couple years it was
gonna be down in los angeles pursuing my
dream of making movies you know it was
always that kind of thing so
the exact moment i don't
recall
but
all those conversations with my parents
were always
you've got to pursue it it's just in you
there's something that you have to
express and
and we support that and so when my
good friend decided at that time he that
wasn't the path for him
obviously i was a little scared and kind
of everything that i had planned was
was you know now
in the open and both my parents were
like
you got this you know you you you uh
have made this plan you should follow
through with it you should do it and
um
and so i did it was very emotional day
the day i left that was really emotional
we you know
helped me pack up a truck and
and with the trailer and kind of
everything i owned packed up in there
and
and uh
ventured out uh
on on my own which just a week earlier i
thought was gonna be
you know with me and my best friend and
um
but yeah i i did it no regrets and and
uh
uh
i think i've always been adventurous in
that way like big big life decisions uh
met and married my wife within one month
um and we've done uh some
uh you know buying from buying houses to
to just uprooting and moving we've done
these things she's very much spontaneous
that way as well
and so we've we've kind of done a lot of
big life decisions we'll we'll
spontaneously make a choice and just go
with it and i think what we understand
is that we're going to have an adventure
no matter what and that
you know and i that's kind of my mindset
as well i'm like
let's just go for it you know let's see
what happens and uh
and uh
and luckily my parents were very
supportive in that way
that's awesome do you still keep in
touch with josh
so we reconnected years later um and yes
so we still keep in touch full circle
kind of coming back he he
lives in portland now and married has a
wonderful family kid
and
he still plays music and uh um and has a
band and all of that so i was doing
my second feature
and when we kind of reconnected through
social media you know it was one of
those things
and uh and i said i've got this
sequence in this movie it's an action
movie and it is this guy trying to go
the straight and narrow so he's trying
to
uh
you know do the right thing in life and
not be part of this criminal underworld
and his friends in the criminal
underworld they're trying to do this
kind of heist thing without him and so
the in the movie it's cross-cut between
him trying to get a regular job and them
going and trying to
shoot up this speakeasy and
both scenes are playing out you know
they're cross-cutting with each other
and i just had this vision of josh
singing this song just hymn and acoustic
guitar this kind of slow melodic
thing that i knew he could do really
well from way back when we were kids
and so when we reconnected i went ah
i've got this i'm doing this movie and
and would you be willing to do an
original song for it and so that kind of
you know full circle friendship came
back and uh and he did and the song is
awesome the very first version he sent
me
it was it
he was like tell me if you want changes
you want no know of course i told him
the story i told him what was going on
and he wrote the lyrics that kind of
matched with it and
but the very first version he sent me
i just it was it i was like nope i don't
need anything else this is what's going
to go in the movie and it did and
and uh and everybody loved that scene
that was like the scene people talked
about in the movie so that was a really
cool thing to be able to reconnect with
him and and i hope to do some more in
the future to get him to do some music
uh for them would be amazing
very cool did you almost not drive down
since since your sort of
partner in crime your your your friend
that sounds like you looked up to him
too a lot um
decided that he didn't want to go i
think that there was definitely that
moment i think there was definitely that
moment of of
you know self-doubt or could i do this
on my own especially because it kind of
had been this
joint dream of ours you know
um
but again i think i had support from my
family and all that that
but sure i definitely had that moment
and felt that way but
uh ultimately
i think
through
the experiences in my life the family
support
also martial arts training i
trained martial art from very very young
i think that probably gave me the
confidence to overcome any of those
doubts
um
and uh
but yeah definitely had it definitely
was there definitely
you know
questioning that uh
whether or not to do it so you're
driving down the five of course obeying
the speed limit i'm sure right
you know what that big old trailer i was
probably going slower than the speed
limit okay and the grapevine was scary
i'm not even gonna lie the great line
coming over that hill in that it was a
it was a old chevy s10 it was
four-cylinder it was gutless and then
having this big old trailer pulling
behind was uh
that was very interesting
right and then you see the part where
it's like if your brakes fail you can go
up this thing you're like why are you
telling me that yeah
yeah
sean if someone were to tell you that
filmmaking is a pipe dream what would
you tell them i've always been a
believer in
and again my parents have probably
get all the credit for this
but
you can accomplish anything you set your
mind to
so there's many things that can be a
pipe dream
if you let them
be a pipe dream but if it's really in
your
core and your soul and your energy to
pursue being a filmmaker
i think you have to pursue it
and that's really up to you if if you
are
someone who
has to express yourself that way
and i also come from that mindset and
maybe it's the martial arts but also
families that never give up never
surrender type of
attitude so
for me
i have
pursued this business in a i think an
interesting way i i've done just about
every job you can do in filmmaking
uh
from hair and makeup to
you know to stunt coordination to
i've always been and i had a mentor
early on in this business who told me to
diversify or die and i've really
kind of took that to heart and as long
as i was working on a film or television
show
i viewed it as number one educational
to the ultimate goal which is you know
directing for myself um
i viewed it as an education and i was
getting to be a part of something that i
love which is telling stories
so
um
i think pipe dreams are
only limited by your own drive
and so
again if
you
don't give up i believe you can make it
so
a lot of the people that i have
been lucky enough to collaborate with
over the years
the stories
are almost the same it's they didn't
give up and all these overnight
successes you you read or hear about
they're usually 10 years 20 years in the
making
and so
it's those people that with that drive
that
end up
having success on a multitude of
different levels
how many people were in the town where
you grew up
uh
roughly like
30 to 50 000 people
is kind of the population when i was
when i was growing up it's probably more
now
uh but it was also a college town so
when college students were in it it was
like double
and did they have a film program there
or not at the time i don't know if they
have a film there is a lot of theater so
like uh my father was a drama professor
he directed two plays a year he produced
shakespeare in the park so there was a
lot of arts that way
as far as film goes i think you can
study some film at both chico state and
and butte college but i don't know if
it's a full-blown film program
at least it wasn't when i grew up there
maybe they do have something like that
now
so did you ever drive down or or fly
down from chico to the la area and see
what it was like here i did so i still
have family who
were down in southern california both
san diego some in in los angeles so
i did spend time and also my
grandparents when i was younger they
still lived in chatsworth
so i spent time
there for that and then
also
i would come down for summers and visit
family
i visited my family down in san diego
from probably like
14
through like 20. i would come down every
summer and stay with my aunt and uncle
um
and
so yeah so i was very familiar with
southern california it wasn't uh
uh wasn't a culture shock when i moved
down here in that way um there was other
things that you know sure i i wasn't
expecting but uh
um i at least had some inclement inkling
you know well i think uh um
moving to uh la itself
i think i didn't fully grasp what
traffic meant
you know even living in san diego
there's traffic but
when you live live in los angeles like
really fully understanding oh that it's
five miles away but that still means an
hour in traffic you know like that
i think those kinds of things i couldn't
prepare for um
and uh
you know
um i certainly think
what i actually thought was interesting
is
sometimes los angeles might get a bad
rap like oh everybody's so rude or this
or that
i think i kind of had an opposite
experience like man people are actually
really nice and you know people say
hello to me all the time and you know
like
so almost i became a defender of los
angeles in that way i'm sure that
there's rude people everywhere and
especially in traffic that's when you
get the rude people i think but
uh you know walking around the streets
of of you know everywhere i mean
hollywood to
to burbank to uh you know the valley um
i've met such wonderful people and and
created such great friendships and
so i think there's a lot of uh uh
misnomer i think same thing with new
york you hear that you know that new
york people might have a chip on their
shoulder or something
but again if you go there and experience
it and live there i think you you'll
find a lot of great people too
sure
it seems like too that you can you kind
of have a way of fitting into any
environment you go in i get that sense
that you you adapt i guess that's
probably true yeah i think i am very
adaptable and i try and uh find common
ground with people and i believe that's
probably a
a great tool to have if you're going to
be a collaborator so myself as a
director or somebody who's captain you
know being the captain of that ship i
try and lead through
uh
that idea of collaboration like we're
all working together for the same goal
i'm definitely not a it's my way or the
highway guy i i do have a strong vision
and i do know what i want but i'm open
to
you know all the different ideas that
can make that vision even better than
maybe what i was expecting so
um
uh
you know so i'm very open-minded that
way and i think that that
open-mindedness is what allows me to be
adaptable and and fit in and work in
different situations and
i've just found it very useful i think
obviously
given my parents and family credit but
also the martial arts angle of it i
think
the philosophy of martial arts is is
very much that way
studying something called tai chi
uh it is all about accepting energy and
redirecting it
versus you know trying to like
you know go head on you know blunt force
uh you know trauma of something it's
more about accepting that energy
redirect if it's something negative you
can let it just go right by you um if
it's something useful you can accept it
and maybe redirect it in in the way that
you're
um you know approaching a
problem-solving
situation or
um
you know being creative
knowing that you had this quote unquote
filmmaking dream and you you figured you
were definitely coming to la and this
was going to be your path what were the
three obstacles the biggest obstacles
that held you back from maybe initially
achieving it or from
um
yeah okay i think
i think some of the biggest obstacles
were maybe just kind of coming from that
maybe smaller town mentality like it
growing up becoming a filmmaker didn't
even actually seem like a plausible
dream you know
it just wasn't even something that i
really thought about it's like oh no you
got to go to college you got to get your
you know
got to get your
associate's degree you know like it just
seemed like a different path so as i
started you know when i made that leap
and moved down to southern california i
didn't go right to la and so maybe there
was part of that
just not you know fully believing
uh it is really possible i think part of
me was like yes it's possible and then
other parts of me were like oh that's
just a you know
how would you even do that how would you
even accomplish that so i think that
that kind of uh
maybe self-doubt is definitely probably
one of the bigger obstacles um
i think
just logistics like like figuring out
what am i going to do when i get there
like how how are you going to
you know just pay rent
so that's probably some of it
and then
again education i think taking those
i took
some
film history classes in in college
and
that really opened my eyes and then also
having a teacher i took a creative
writing class and then discovered he
also taught a script writing class and
so i ended up taking that as well so i
think some of that education also helped
um
me decide that yes i could you know
pursue this in it at some level
um
and sorry didn't it's already interrupt
but you actually took the same class
three times so the the the history of
film class that was was taught at san
marcos college uh down in
the san diego area was a great class so
i took the first class and it was alfred
hitchcock and so we went through the
um
his film history like from the very
first film he did all the way to the
last film
and uh we didn't watch every film but we
you know from the different eras we he
would pick a film and we'd watch it and
so we broke it down we studied the
techniques we the different things that
they you know the filmmaker would like
to do and uh how they interacted with
actors like the full thing it was
fascinating and i loved it
and uh
at the end of the semester i asked him
you know do you do the same
filmmaker every time he goes no every
semester is different like well who are
you doing next he's i'm going to do
stanley kubrick i'm like oh my god i've
got to take this class again so i did i
ended up taking it three times during my
time there and studied three different
filmmakers
and uh i didn't get credit at all on the
basically just auditing the class um
but i just really wanted to learn about
those filmmakers and i think that was a
really great education
um
and then it was a different teacher for
the creative writing and script writing
but
i think after getting that education
probably helped boost my confidence
and then i met and married my wife and
she was like why are we in san diego
and i had done a short film and she
loved it
she was
you know
rooting in my corner she's like this is
amazing you've got to go we put in some
film festivals and did good with it but
um
but it was really her saying
you can do all this from san diego but
you know why not go and try you know try
it up there and so we did we moved up
there on a whim
and uh
the rest is history i ended up
i was doing personal training when i
first moved to la to to pay the bills
but i got a job really quickly in
in
[Music]
production being a pa and doing all that
stuff no job was ever too small for me i
was never afraid of hardware i did extra
work as well and i would i would bring a
notebook and painted i would take notes
and i would study and try and learn like
i viewed it as an opportunity to get on
set and see what it's all about learn
the terms what do they all mean what's
that person's got to be in a mark okay
what you know what's minimal focus
distance mean i
literally would would try and learn
every aspect of what was going on
uh and again i felt i treated it like i
was getting paid to get an education
so
so i had no problem i did i did extra
work for probably nine months ended up
getting my sag card through that
um
and at the same time i was personal
training and then i got the pa job on a
tv show and uh
self through my own little short films
and things like that
in commercials i had taught myself
how to edit uh on on you know on a mac
uh one of the early
like imovie and final cut was first
coming out and the whole adobe suites
were just starting out when i was was
doing that so i taught myself all the
all the different little tools from
photoshop to after effects
um
you know to editing and uh so i had some
of those skills for my own short films
and that pa job i did on a television
show of course i put on my resume
i can do final cut i can do after
effects i can do that
and it wasn't even a week into that
production when
they said hey we saw you do after
effects on uh on your resume like we
were under you know some crazy deadlines
do you think you could help with some
rotoscoping
i'm like oh yeah i've done that before
you know
so they gave me a couple shots and i did
them i turned them in they're like oh
this looks really good you think you
could do some more oh sure sure yeah no
problem so i think that attitude of
always
just being there ready to help ready to
work
helped me excel
uh through
through this business like like wildfire
so
one week into being a coffee runner on
this tv show
the very next so i stayed they go what
do you think you can work on a saturday
and help us no problem i'll be there
showed up help did did many different
things for visual effects not just
rotoscoping i ended up compositing some
pieces i ended up um doing some like uh
lighting effects and different things in
there
by that monday i was uh
a vfx
artist on the show
then one week later i became the lead
green screen
uh effects artist on the show
so just within two weeks just because i
was ready to go i was willing to put in
the work and
um just having that
positive attitude and also uh
um like when we first started talking
about this being able to kind of
uh
blend in or or fit into any situation
um having that flexibility is i think
what helped me excel and that happened
on other shows as well um
i was a assistant stunt coordinator on a
show
and
literally the third day of filming i
ended up becoming the second unit
director on that show oh wow and it
literally had to do with i think
perception is also being perceptive is
also a handy tool
um
i was
helping this the stunt coordinator
helped with casting all the stunt uh
people for this show and it was an
action orientated show
so we had to choreograph and rehearse
and do all these things
and i saw the executive producer pacing
on like day two back and forth
frustrated
and
just being you know just trying to be a
nice guy just hey are you okay you know
he starts telling me about how
they're not making their days and they
don't know what to do and
uh
the director's moving too slow and and i
just threw out there just going hey well
you know the stunt coordinator and
myself we're both directors and i had
actually already directed a feature at
that point
and
i said if you gave us a camera we could
you know
more than likely help you
guys film stuff and and hopefully make
your day i said whatever scenes you want
to give us whatever pieces you want to
give us i know we could handle it
and the very next day he showed up
with a
little like skeleton camera crew and
said sean all right you're going to
second unit direct this stuff which at
that point i got actually a little bit
terrified because
i was now going over my boss's head the
stunt coordinator
because like the second unit director's
almost the next step up
and so
immediately went to him like oh my gosh
i told him that you and i are both
directors because we have both directed
that us as a team could help
i didn't say that i should be the
director you know and and luckily he's a
great friend of mine i've probably done
the most work with him than anybody else
in this business
uh noelle vega is his name
a wonderful wonderful uh
friend and uh collaborator in this
business for me
we've probably done over 100 projects
together because we've worked on video
games together we've worked on stunt
stuff we he's been a producer and i've
been a director on projects uh tel
entire television series we've done
together so we've really done a lot of
stuff over the years and he just
he's also one of my mentors and kind of
like that big brother
uh
in this industry uh for myself but so i
was mortified in that situation going i
by no means was trying to go over your
head or try and pass you up
and uh luckily he was like
i'm so busy as the stunt coordinator
he's like you go do this
you go do it and he championed me for
that and
and uh
it worked out well because whatever i
shot was good enough for them i guess
and so then i became the second unit
director for the whole series and then
ended up fully directing several
episodes as the season went on and into
season two but that's an important
lesson it sounds like because you
learned to like go to him so it didn't
seem like you were trying to go behind
his back yes that's a very stereotypical
thing that happens in this industry and
people
do it all the time and yeah
yeah yeah i found out
well at least it's been my experience
that loyalty
um
in a positive way obviously there could
you know loyalty
could
in certain situations maybe not be a
great thing but sure most situations is
a good thing but but for myself my
personal experience loyalty has been a
very um positive uh
tool um and i've only grown
from those loyalties and those
friendships and those you know i've
never and i'm just not that person as
well i don't wanna
ever you know betray or step on somebody
to get to get to that next level i'm
much more the person let's all build
ourselves up together we're stronger as
a team
and you know i love the whole brat pack
and the rat packs and that whole idea
like let's make our own film family and
and grow and uh
and and uh
do it that way uh versus i'm gonna climb
to the top and step on whoever i can to
get there you know i think in some ways
it's a slower process right
not just stepping on people and getting
to the top as fast as you can
but
obviously i think it's a more fulfilling
way to do it and
i have stayed positive and happy in this
business i've been in it now 20 years
um versus feeling you know
jaded or
hate myself for the things that i've
done you know what i mean uh type of
thing
what was your first job growing up like
an after-school job oh my gosh um i
don't know why it's coming to my it's
like i'm just seeing like you doing
something and i can't totally see what
it is but i was so busy yeah and you
know i'm one of those people who likes
doing a lot of things at once like if
you give me one task it's probably way
harder for me than if you give me three
tasks right so i think uh uh
my first job
technically my very first job was
teaching martial arts oh really so
that's what it was and uh
kind of i would i would teach a class
here and there as a teenager as a
teenager and then i went and got a job
at taco bell
and i worked at taco bell because i
really wanted to save up for the honda
civic hatchback nice so i was like 15
and a half and i started working at taco
bell
and my martial arts master uh the the
the head honcho of the system the karate
is a shorin ru karate
a very very traditional okinawan karate
he came through the drive-through and he
saw me there and he's like
why are you working here and i go what
do you mean why am i working here i'm
gonna i'm saving up for this car and he
goes but you could be working at the
dojo
and i'm like i can he goes yeah i'll pay
you to teach classes like
so i did so i i i did work there for a
little while longer but then i i went to
the to the uh school to the martial arts
school and i taught full-time
uh for years and years
but i did have multiple jobs still i
also worked in a stereo store i also
worked at a local uh baseball
like for the baseball seasons i would go
and work there so i always liked having
a lot of jobs and and then i also
started directing those commercials at
that same period
um so yeah i had like three or four jobs
kind of always uh
going on but uh but martial arts i guess
it was
because i did teach some classes so it's
either martial arts or taco bell toss-up
between the two but
those were the first jobs what a great
story so he when you went to give him
his order like he's like yeah i'll have
the numbers i was working the
drive-through
and then okay great did you watch this
yeah and then and then you're like oh my
gosh it's him okay yeah well that's a
great moment right yeah it was it was
pretty uh it was pretty funny and uh
and just the look on his face he's like
no come teach at the school you know so
but you know what i think working at
taco bell also taught me a lot of great
lessons and sure people's skills yeah
all of those i think all those things
are important and and i have kids and i
want them to get you know they're going
to have to earn a car in the same way i
did i had to i saved up now my parents
did help me with some i think they paid
for the insurance and stuff like that on
the car but um
i think there was something so
fulfilling about that experience and and
earning something like that i think it
was 2700 at the time for the car wow and
i that took me you know six months at
taco bell and and several more months at
teaching martial arts to save up for it
but i did and i just
i loved that car i mean that was you
know because i earned it you know it's
the first like bigger item that i earned
so certainly something in the thousands
of dollars you know i'd bought
i
saved up and bought bikes and things
like that but never
um
you know i think that's part of that
coming of age and you know oh yeah all
that stuff so what was the first song
you blasted through the stereos because
did you get your stereo from the stereo
store of course oh you did of course and
i had a really big booming stereo it was
ridiculous it was absolutely ridiculous
you go down to like a cruise strip or a
room of course of course
i'm trying to think of what it would
have been at the time
um i like smaller towns have that
gorgeous circles oh yeah especially
downtown chico it's definitely a cruise
that's you do a loop and and we would
when i was 16 we would do the loop we
would circle several times and
and thought we were very cool uh with
our ridiculous stereos
um it's a rite of passage yeah yeah
everybody's definitely definitely felt
like uh
an 80s version of
american graffiti you know it was very
much that um which is funny because i've
shot several movies in petaluma and
that's american graffiti was was shot
some of it was shot there as well the
whole cruising the strip was shot in
petaluma oh very cool um but uh yeah i'm
trying to remember i i listen to such a
variety of music i also play music so i
play guitar and bass and mess around on
the drums and stuff so i've always have
such a respect for
music kind of in all genres so i
honestly i you know maybe i don't listen
to as much country but there's still a
lot of country that i really
view as amazingly you know
artistic and talented people performing
it so i will listen or maybe it's uh you
know
opera maybe i'm not an opera guy every
day on my stereo but there's some
amazing music and such amazing talent
that i have respect for it so
um i'm trying to think of what
everything from tom petty to oh nice
might have been a tom petty song i
listened a lot used to love the cars
back then oh yeah yeah
i played a lot of that but then i'd play
on the opposite end of spectrum i would
play you know
bob marley to zap and roger to
frank zappa to you know like i really i
really was uh i kind of have a very
broad spectrum of music that i love eric
clapton i was like obsessed with eric
clapton when i was 16. nice that's kind
of that's when i was really getting into
playing the guitar and stuff was
listening to everything he did um
so okay yeah probably tom petty or
something probably free falling right
okay probably blast in and you know head
out the window like ace ventura at the
time or something and the arm too yeah
oh yeah totally totally yeah
when you first moved to los angeles and
started working whether it was a little
side job or in the industry did you work
any jobs for free were you willing to
take unpaid work so
yes i did lots of
pro bono work and just to get experience
or
um
you know that kind of stuff again
you have to do it to a degree because of
course you still have to make sure
you're doing something to earn you know
some kind of income to to pay rent and
get some food and all of that
but yeah there was plenty of times and i
did it for years not every time but
something would come up like hey this is
a
unpaid gig but we need we could use some
help or you know anytime i had the
opportunity once i got a little bit of
stability with work
i would still do those
i don't do it as much anymore just
because i don't have the time
but if those windows of time do open up
i you know
never have an issue with volunteering
some time
to help somebody out
but yeah in the beginning there was a
bunch of credit building stuff that i
was willing to do
um
because again i would view it as a like
like i said an education i knew i was
going to learn something and i knew i
was going to meet some new people and
those two things are incredibly valuable
especially in this business
you hear all the time it's who you know
that's 100 true that is what this
business is it is who you know it's the
relationships you build it's not
necessarily the oh somebody's giving
favoritism or whatever i'm sure those
things happen too
but it is about if you came and
volunteered on somebody's shoot and you
did a great job
uh helping them with whatever it was
when they have a paid job they're going
to call you too you know what i mean and
that's that's how it works um and uh
and those friendships and those and even
just business relationships uh
have almost always led to
a paying job in some way shape or form
and
i tell people all the time when they're
asking about getting into this business
like what's the what's the best thing i
could do i said create something just
create doesn't even matter what it is
put some energy into it put some
creative energy and create something
because you're going to call some
friends and see if they're available
they're going to ask some people
whatever however that's going to work
and you're going to create something now
you can show people something you've
created and at the same time you've now
strengthened some relationships or maybe
met some new people and that network
starts building up of who you know
and and they now know what you do
and you know it kind of goes from there
i've had people who i hadn't worked with
in six years call me up for a job
because whatever impression i made way
back then
it somehow came around and i came up or
they saw me on social media posting
something and here's my new you know
short film on youtube and they go i
remember him i worked with him on you
know and so it's all about that it's all
about relationship building so
um doing the free jobs
to me it it's always
beneficial if you have the means to do
it obviously don't put yourself out on
the street because you're taking 20 free
jobs and you have no way to pay your
bills but within reason
i say do it because you're going to gain
experience and you're also going to gain
relationships
of those times that you worked for free
for credit for something on your wheel
whatever how much of that actually led
to paid work down the line i think that
that
quite a few of them did and again i
think it has to do with
how much energy you're willing to put
into something i never approached a free
job as like that's a free job i'm going
to have you know half ass this job i
always approached it is i'm going to do
the best i can do work as hard as i can
to help the project be successful um
and i think because of that mindset and
attitude i made enough an impression on
people that
that they wanted to hire me for when
they got the paying gig or whatever you
know what i mean so i think
again i think almost every one of those
jobs i met and and created a friendship
or or
working relationship with
at least a few people on each one of
those sets that then led to me getting
called for something else even it was
low paying you know like hey
can you help out with this you know i
enjoyed working with you on that
can you uh you know i'm really trying to
think of any of that that led kind of
that never got a phone call that way
but um
[Music]
i just i can't really think of one that
didn't i think they all kind of led in
some way sometimes it wasn't right away
like i said
um
but they eventually um
almost all of them led to something
positive in that way uh and again it's i
think
just chalking it up to to
hard work not being afraid of hard work
you know
luckily i think
again my family my parents ingrained
that into me enough uh
that uh
i've never been afraid to put that work
in and
and be the last person on set and you
know
even as a director when i can get away
with it i'll help put stuff away certain
job you know union issues you can't do
that
but
um
if i am in that situation where i can i
do now go why is the director carrying c
stands like because
we're all in this together you know what
i mean um
obviously it doesn't get to work out
that way every time but when it does i
was overseas doing a project and they
didn't have the same
rules so i was
there loading trucks with all of them
you know
um and trying not to get in the way
because sometimes you can get in their
way you know like and now i'm making us
go slower because i don't know what i'm
doing but
uh you know when it when it's
appropriate then i try and help out
whenever i can
and i love your website in that you you
not only have great photos of you on set
and things like that but you you say
here's who i've worked with here's what
i do and you really like break it down
and i was very impressed with how you
did it and you did you do it in a fun
way where it's not it's not like you're
it's over the top you know i i was very
impressed with that i don't think i've
seen that before thank you uh yeah a lot
of that credit needs to go to actually
my cousin uh jeremy dunn who helped me
build that website
um and he's really great with that stuff
and and uh
and i felt so
just humbled that the the actors that i
worked with they gave such great quotes
i was like oh my gosh i don't know if i
deserve this but they they really were
helpful in that way and
and uh i really really appreciated um
them
putting the time into even putting some
of those responses and
um but yeah it was always the goal to
kind of just make it presentable and
like here's here's what i do and
and uh um
uh
you know obviously the goal is to make
myself hirable
you know and and
and
kind of showcase some of the things that
i you know
hopefully help me stand apart maybe from
the pack
with with my experiences from from the
action side of things to the visual
effects side of things
and i think that's also
an important
thing to think about for any aspiring
filmmakers is
is uh you know figuring out what you can
do that helps you
uh stand apart or
um
makes you at least uh
unique in some certain way because uh
those little things can help you know
can help you uh
maybe edge edge out the competition for
uh i've certainly had it where um not
only the action side of things have
helped get me jobs but also the visual
effects side
and the combination of both sometimes
has has helped me um
because you know i'll get hey you know
we want you to direct this
because we know you're also really good
at action
i've gotten that call a bunch of times
where
instead of just hiring a director who
maybe doesn't have that experience it's
the combination of those experiences
that have helped get me the job
or like with visual effects i got a
pretty big tv series
based on my experience with visual
effects and obviously directing they
liked my directing good that checked
that box but now it's a it's a vfx heavy
show oh my gosh he's also a vfx
consultant like wow okay that checks
another box he can work directly with
the visual effects artists and make sure
that they're shooting it correctly and
so that helps just edge me out so having
those skills um
for those things are what helps me in a
lot of situations um to maybe get hired
for a job
but it could be many you know a variety
of of tool sets that you have
but it's it's i think important to
uh
you know lean into those things and try
and present those things let make sure
people know that you can do those things
like you know if you're uh
uh
you know somebody who's amazing with
horses or whatever that could actually
be a big skill i could help you direct a
movie about rodeos or you know what i
mean like so all those things are are
kind of important to help you stand out
for for what you do you know what i mean
and without of course naming names what
was one of the worst grunt jobs you ever
had and how did you get through it
because i get the sense that you try to
take a positive spin with everything
even if it's not positive and i admire
that um maybe just one that was so
unbearable but somehow you got through
it and i don't know if you took
something with you in terms of learning
something or yeah always yeah always
always
learning i think
i mean i guess the grip work is it's a
lot of physical work so that was tough
but uh it wasn't like
i didn't feel bad
you know during the experience so that's
tough to say that i i had a great time
but um there's been a there was a job
where i was a
second a.d
and just the conditions were so tough i
think that was the
like below freezing temperatures and
then blazing hot in the day we're out in
the middle of the mojave desert
so and i was asked to be the first a.d
on it
but i
kind of got
i don't know how to say it exactly but i
just got a bad feeling about the project
so i tried actually not to do it but i
had some some other friends who really
wanted the job like want needed the work
and by me turning it down then i
wouldn't be able to get all of them on
to the project
so i said look i'm not going to be the
first id because uh
i just i smell a disaster coming
basically
and
i said look i will help you i said why
don't you to one of my friends i said
how about you be the first ad i'll be
your second
and uh you know i'll help you with
whatever you need help with
um
uh
if you want to do it i said but i'm
warning you right now that we probably
shouldn't do this
and uh it just had to do with the people
involved and and lack of experience and
the extreme conditions we are going to
be in
so i knew that
it was going to be
difficult in a way that shouldn't be
difficult you know and that's like in
the way of like making sure people are
taken care of and all that and sure
enough we
trying to survive the the desert in that
time that we were in the below freezing
temperatures and
um not having adequate uh
things like warming tents and stuff like
that to keep cast number one
warm and we did end up some people ended
up getting hypothermia and yeah it was
bad it was bad um but uh we made it
through it so
um but yeah there was uh that was a very
very interesting experience and of
course i learned a ton from that
experience i learned uh
chief among them that you know what to
accept and not accept
um because we said yes to certain things
that we should not have said yes to
because it ended up being
um
dangerous you know like physically
dangerous for some for for certain
things so um but but again i don't
regret the experience because again
uh what i learned from it
really really helped me literally on i
think it was two projects later i'm like
nope here's the life experience i now
have from this this is why i won't do
this and this is why i think you guys
shouldn't do this and they actually
listen to me they go okay all right fair
enough blah blah blah you know so it
actually became a tool for myself on on
another project
of having that experience and going
look we had two actresses that got
hypothermia do you want it oh no we
don't okay well then this is what i
think you should do here's the steps i
think that we didn't take on this
project that i think should have been
taken
and um
so by doing that i had that experience
to draw from and if the actresses were
fine they they recovered and everything
but
but
yeah it was that was a difficult one to
get through probably the most
probably the most and i guess as a
second idea i don't know if that's
really considered a grunt job but
um
that was the most difficult one i think
a producer gave you some advice that was
pretty lasting
yeah so um i i was a personal trainer at
the time and i was still you know i was
doing short films and and and all of
that stuff i think i was making my first
feature which was a back alley you know
group of friends putting their credit
cards you know into the pot and just
making a making a film
uh i think i was doing that at the time
and i was he was somebody who was very
integral developing
the fast and furious franchise as well
as the the show
24.
and uh he just happened to be one of my
clients and
and
we uh
you know became friends uh from the
whole thing and he was
gave me some great advice uh um
and one of the things he he told me was
number one he said don't be a a-hole
that was one of the biggest rules so
this business is so small
that if you're
a jerk it's gonna come back around
um so that was one of the first things
he told me he's like
and he was very colorful in the way he
explained it but
um he's like that
pa that you're working with on set
one week
a year later they might be producing the
show that you're working on
you know it's that that's the way this
business works so if you're a jerk to
that extra
they might be the star of some show in a
year or two so you just never you know
you should never
treat people you know poorly and
especially
i mean that's just in life but
especially in this business because it
is really so small you're end up going
to have to work with the same people
again most likely
and the other thing he told me was if i
really wanted to pursue being a
creator
a storyteller a filmmaker
to
never be a you know no job is too small
never be afraid of of
being the coffee runner or being the in
charge of extras or whatever it is
and also to diversify so
the business was changing so much at
that time it was when uh digital was
just coming out it was kind of taking
over everything um
and uh
even dvds and that whole blu-ray
everything that was
the industry was just shifting and
shifting and shifting so he told me to
diversify or die those were his exact
words
if you want to make it and survive in
this business diversify or die and i
took that to heart
and that's why if you look up my credits
you'll see i've done
so many different jobs is because i
basically adopted the attitude of
just not turning down a job so if i was
offered a job
and i had the ability to do it and i had
the time to do it
that i would do it and and again it goes
back to that viewing it as a
an education it's like oh i'm going to
learn about this and he also told me
that same thing of look if you learn
what it is to be a grip
and if you learn what what it takes to
be the the you know
art department if you learn those things
it's going to make you a better director
because you'll understand what it takes
to do those jobs and you'll understand
what they're going through to do those
jobs in the same perspective
it's a very important for a director to
be understand acting
because you'll then be able to
understand the process or understand
that there is a process with actors and
be able to sympathize with them or help
enable them tell their truth in that
role same thing with uh editing as a
director i think it's so important to
understand editing because you
understand what you're shooting there
are directors who are not editors
but i think you need to have a certain
understanding of that in order to be
effective it helps you with time
management on set it helps you when you
know you have your scene you know you
don't need to shoot four more angles
that you'll never use and be on the
cutting room floor because you know you
have the scene it's there you've got all
the pieces you need um
so
those two things i already knew were
important to be a director but i didn't
think about the other stuff the the what
is the gaffer doing what is the grips
doing what are the makeup and hair and
you know kind of learning all those
different departments it's only going to
help you become a better director is
what he told me and and so i took that
to heart and i took every job i could
take i did everything i could do and and
just
felt like it was a an education for me
um and and would just help me be better
at the job that i was trying to
pursue
do you ever feel guilty turning down
work
um
you mean now
yeah my sense is that you're
eager and you love what you do that if
an opportunity comes up you almost feel
bad if you can't take it because maybe
totally committed to something else yes
yes yeah for sure
and uh
what's interesting uh and and topical
right now is that i had to back out of
directing a film
uh overseas because of the pandemic and
actually i was over there when it
started getting really bad i was over
there prepping and it's gonna be a
fantastic film i am uh now kind of
jealous that i
didn't get to direct it but
um when this whole thing first came up i
started getting bad and and
uh was definitely really worried
about getting home because it became one
of those things of uh
you know at the time they're like you
know what you could just stay a couple
extra weeks and wait it out and then
when it's safe to travel again you know
it was one of those and but what
what ended up happening was the
international flight started cancelling
like just stopping all international
flights and i went
i think i'm going to have to go home
because i can't get stuck here
i've got a family and all that so i did
i ended up getting home
and uh on the last weekend where those
international flights were flying
i got home and uh did the quarantine did
all that stuff got tested and i was fine
but uh the
it the whole thing got pushed because of
it
and but then it came down to this thing
when they wanted to shoot it still was
just not a safe time to be to go and
travel and and the worry of being able
to get home was so
uh
you know
just too big of a worry it was just too
much uh to to be able to commit and go
there and do it and i felt horrible
turning that down because i had
committed to doing this project with
with these wonderful filmmakers
and uh
some of which i had really dreamed about
working with for a long time
because they were a big part of asian
cinema like with with
you know jetley and jackie chan and all
that and so i had to turn it down i felt
so so bad
um
but obviously it's not under my control
it was out of my control
the whole situation so
but yeah i think i do
feel that way because
um
i just enjoy
i enjoy creating and and helping tell
stories in
in whatever the capacity whether it's
you know even if it's stunt coordinating
that's still your part of telling that
story you're part of telling the the
story of the action of how it's
happening and unfolding and i just love
i love that process so
and i think there's also that element of
feeling like you might be able to help
somebody
uh
and then not being able to you know
having to say no i can't help you
because i get those those uh
calls uh
you know fairly often it's it's somebody
usually when they're calling me because
they need your piece of expertise or
something uh that you know you might be
able to
be that puzzle piece for them
and then when you're not available uh
obviously that's
that sucks but i always try and
recommend somebody i'm like call this
person or i'm definitely that that way
as well i really love to
to if i can't do it get somebody else
the work you know what i mean
um
and so i do that
we're gonna break the fourth wall here
and we're gonna title this video how to
get four movies on netflix in two years
now we just need you to give us the nuts
and bolts
of how that happens and then we can put
that title on it okay
so now uh um
are you saying from start to finish
yeah what what so what are the four
movies and what are their genres maybe
we'll start with that okay sure sure
so uh yeah i i
was lucky enough to uh
get to direct and and work on
uh four films that have all been
released in this year 2020 on netflix um
which is kind of mind-boggling i was
never planned that way i think
this year has brought a lot of
curveballs and
a lot of people were looking for a lot
of content so it kind of worked out but
the first movie i did that was released
on netflix was roped and it's a kind of
coming of age a little bit of like a
teen romance
some have described it as like a
footloose meets
you know a western or something or a
rodeo movie
and
that was wonderful to work on um and the
two leads of that are josh and lauren
swickard at the time lauren york but
they actually met and fell in love on
the set it was a real life romance going
on at the same time that we were filming
that movie the second movie i did was
lady driver that was led by grace van
dien and she's i think a wonderful
wonderful actress i think she's a big
big star in the making and of course
sean patrick flannery uh was in that
with her as well and also her dad did a
cameo casper van bean
and
that's about a young
woman who becomes a race car champion or
pursues becoming a race car champion
kind of in her it's kind of in her
family blood and so again it's a coming
of age it's her kind of uh figuring all
that stuff out finding out about her
past that she didn't know about
um
and then after that was this really zany
comedy it's my first feature comedy um
i've love absolutely adore comedy and
even in action films i i try and put in
comedy i just love
the opportunity and the vehicle to try
and make people smile in any which way
that i can so
i'd done comedic commercials in the past
and i've done short films that are that
are comedy but never a feature so this
was my first feature comedy and i had an
absolute blast making it's probably the
most fun i've ever had on a set the
actors and matt jones and noreen dewolfe
and maddie carderoppal and uh
um
they're just we're so funny that
you know
in front of the camera off the camera
they're so funny that just the whole
experience was
just absolutely hilarious and john ducey
who wrote it was also in it
he's hilarious and uh and his wife uh
christina moore is also in it so they're
just all such a funny cast
along with ali afshar
um
that uh that one's that one's kind of uh
i don't know if many people will know
this movie but there's a movie called uh
um
brewster's millions and it's the
basically the the nuts and bolts of it
is uh
estranged father
um leaves his fortune and his will to uh
to his his son
and uh
um in our movie the son
uh
he has two other siblings who believe
they should be the heirs to the to the
family fortune
but on his deathbed the father
leaves a challenge for his his estranged
son to be able to
get the family fortune if he competes
in
these races across the country and he
has to podium it's totally not
believable it's totally over the top but
basically he has to go across the
country and compete in different races
from motorcycle like motocross to
drag
drag boats to monster trucks i mean like
we did we went across the gamut of the
the racing world and just had a blast
with it
and then the last one is which just came
out is california christmas
and that's just a very sweet kind of
rom-com christmas movie
and
that again stars
josh and laurence wickard and this time
she wrote the script um laurence wickard
wrote it and produced it and along with
ali afshar but it was a great reunion
with them both acting in it now married
and um
uh
we
became very again what we talked about
earlier about you know the relationships
you build it really
that's exactly what this was all about
we had a great experience on one project
and we're trying to figure out what to
do
you know in the future when the time was
right what can we do again together and
this is the vehicle that came up for
that and uh
i jumped at the chance as soon as i got
called and said hey do you want to
direct another movie with josh and
lauren i'm like
yes what is the well first obviously i
got to read the script but almost like
not even knowing the script it was
already like a yes like you know yes i
want to do another film with them
because it was just such an enjoyable
experience and and uh this one it's the
big city guy comes and he's trying to
buy the property from the from the the
ranch from the young woman who who uh
owns the ranch and so it's that kind of
thing and he gets dragged into doing
work on the on the ranch and of course
they fall in love and uh you know it's
that kind of thing but there's some good
little twists in it and there's some
really fun characters that are
unexpected
uh in there and uh
you know you've got david del rio
who's a really great comedic actor
just a great actor in general but he's
also really really good at comedy um
and
he's really funny in this movie so
we had a lot of fun with that and uh
yeah they all all of them ended up on
netflix uh this past year and or this
year and that was uh
uh i felt just very blessed that that uh
is a reality you know that that happened
wasn't expecting it um you know you're
making these movies you don't
necessarily know when they're gonna come
out
um
[Music]
but uh yeah they they all did
and so how does that happen is that
something where you knew up front that
you were making these
to eventually be on netflix a
distributor got them on
the producer had inroads yeah so the
first three no
um the first three we didn't know
exactly what the distribution path would
be
california christmas is a netflix
original so yes we did know from the
get-go on that one
and there's that collaboration
so
that was really exciting when we were
doing it too just knowing that we that
that that's going to be the home this is
you know
[Music]
just a really and obviously then there's
the pressures of making sure you do it
right and do it justice and
make them happy and everything but
the first three no we we we made them
with you know obviously netflix would be
a a great place for them to land so you
shoot for those
shoot for that as a goal of course um
but
uh
you know obviously there's
uh amazon and there's hulu and there's
there's theatrical there's you know just
going a traditional route like you know
itunes or whatever so there's all sorts
of
different uh avenues you could go
but i definitely think netflix was a
goal place to try and get them
and luckily with the relationships
that the production team and
like our producers like ali afshar
um the relationships he's built uh have
helped us get us into those doors um and
ultimately get um
you know find their home there
has has he had other movies on netflix
did he already have a pre-existing
relationship so
um
i think with roped
the cut several of them got released the
same day so i think it was a
a um
kind of a little bit of a package deal
there
so i'm not exactly sure if there was
anything before that that had made it
onto netflix
i think those were the first ones
so
no not necessarily but
um
relationships with with like we kind of
have a
kind of loose partnership like sales
partnership with warner brothers
so
that relationship was already
established
um and so i think it was through that
relationship again some of this stuff is
above my pay grade
um but i do know that we we have
partnered especially on the sales ends
of things with warner brothers in the
past and so that has been kind of a um
a very good relationship there with with
several movies and then when it came to
this um
again i am not 100 sure but i think that
was the the the relationship that then
uh bridged into netflix
so so ali has these relationships and is
this from i know he has a racing does
something with racism so yeah so yeah
ali ali um is uh
again now i've done more movies with him
than i've done with anybody else
so our partnership him producing me
directing i've done five films with him
um
and uh obviously i keep coming back
because i love working with him and uh
again it's another really
just great friendship that has developed
um
uh over the years and
so um
he started he's got a great story so he
uh
grew up in northern california i also
grew up in northern california so
there's a little bit of that you know
bond there but he uh got into racing
uh
kind of in a roundabout way but i mean
he was always into racing but how he got
sponsorships and everything was
him and his
team his buddies they figured out uh
how to
um
take a subaru
and
modify it in a way to be
obviously incredibly fast but compete in
drag racing and at that time subaru
they're rally racing and they did other
things other kinds of racing but
came nowhere near drag racing but
the way how he was able to figure out
how to take i believe it's a six
cylinder and like drag race with these
huge muscle cars and wind
was kind of
revolutionary and especially for
for subaru themselves and so
if i'm remembering the story correctly
they came out to meet him and he took
them in the car and showed him what it
could do
and they wanted to sponsor him so he
traveled the world did all these races
and and got even
you know more advanced with the subarus
and took them to like
world record holding numbers and he uh i
believe he still holds some world
records with to his team and subaru um
with the drag racing so he did really
well for himself there and through
different sponsorship deals that's how
he met other sponsors who then
became hey why don't we make some movies
together would you want to make a movie
about race cars you know what i mean so
it became that that's how he kind of got
into that whole world and i think he had
also just done some acting on the side
because that was another passion of his
i know he was on like king of queens he
kind of had a character who would come
back every so often and i know he did
some some of the stuff early on as well
i don't know where that overlaps with
him making movies and all of that but
he kind of tried to marry his two loves
i think which was racing and acting and
and uh and all of that so
um they ended up making a couple race
car movies first okay um and then that
started bridge bridging out from there
started expanding into other stories to
tell not just racing but we do always
kind of come back to the racing too
because that is obviously a big passion
of his so even like our comedy wheels of
fortune
um that i was describing earlier it's
obviously all the different race car
elements i mean from the motorcycles to
the boats to the
off-road trucks to the you know
it's uh um
we do find ways to do
do stories that uh also involve the
racing right so interesting so he has
this
sort of mindset of of finding sponsors
and and partnering what he loves to do
with these bigger companies he's really
good at that again he's really good at
those relationship building and
and uh that we talked about earlier he's
uh
he's very personable very nice guy all
of those things and and
and has great ideas and has
you know this incredible ambition and
and uh i think his energy is infectious
that way as well so i think
um
he attracts uh those kinds of uh
people that with like-minded uh you know
energy and want want to create these
things and so um i think he's produced
it's really hard to keep track of them
all i think he's produced 16 movies
and two television series now and all
within a matter of you know
five years or something like that or
maybe even under that
so um
yeah when he sets his mind to those
things he's he really excels and then
luckily i was able to to partner uh with
him and that was through um again it we
talk about how
uh work begets work right so
um it was an actor
named shane graham who's also a
wonderful actor i think he's a big star
as well
and he's he's doing really great work
he's got a movie right now called ride
which is on amazon
and uh
that one's doing really really well and
again that's the same same filmmaker ali
afshar is also the producer of that so
he had just finished filming that when
he came onto a tv series i was directing
and we became fast friends and
he
said man i got to introduce you to these
other filmmakers
and he in kind told them you've got to
meet this director sean you know i think
you guys would get along great so it's
really him helping bridge that
relationship and then um some of the
producers not ali came to set and
actually uh the other director the other
main director for for ali's company esx
entertainment uh alex uh rena revello
has directed i think he's directed like
at least ten movies with them i've done
five he's yeah yeah
and uh um
so he um
he came to set he came to visit it's
almost like the the
you know if if he approved of me then
they would take a meeting with me type
of thing and he was lovely and and uh he
came to set and visited when we were we
were launching some b-25 bomber it was a
world war ii thing
and uh i'll be like perfect day for him
to come see we're doing some really cool
stuff you know so he came and visited
and
and uh
luckily
he reported back that that i seemed like
you know maybe a good match for them as
well so i went out to warner brothers
and and met up with ali and and again i
think we we hit it off right away and i
really liked the story the the movie
that they were um
uh talking to me about directing at the
time is called american fighter
and that comes out in
early early 2021 it's it's finally
coming out so that one's been
uh
it's been a while since we
first started that one but it's finally
coming out i believe in march is when
that one's going to come out but
so i met with them and
luckily they they
liked me enough and and the rest is
history i then did four more movies
after that one with them and hopefully
more knock on wood
i would love to do of course more
projects with them
wow that's really fascinating so because
i think ali when i read his bio i said
he he was going to med school and then
he became he wanted to be an actor
instead and then the race car driving
came in there and then is that that's
fascinating then yeah and then yeah find
the sponsorship and that would take him
back to acting exactly yeah yeah yeah
it's really
uh
it's really uh
amazing and he's a great producer that
way i mean he
he's he's just one of those people that
any problem even you know i i
view myself as a great problem solver
but i even run into certain issues that
you know maybe i can't tackle he comes
in and it's and he fixes it you know i
we were shooting lady driver and
it had just rained and we're on this
it's this really nasty kind of clay
that just will your cars will sink in it
and all that kind of stuff and you won't
get them out like it's one of those
things so it had rained a couple days
before we were at this racetrack and
we're supposed to film everything in
there in their race pits
and but the problem is it had rained a
couple days and the the the track the
guy running the track was like i don't
think you can bring these big heavy
you know production trucks and vehicles
on here
and he goes we'd have to bring in a
tractor and we'd have to like you know
lay down like like till it up and lay
down some more stuff and blah blah i'm
like well where are we gonna film this
you know like this is
here today is here's our schedule this
is what we're supposed to film on this
day and i kept talking to the guy going
what can we do where can we film it can
we do it here or is there any way
to to make it work there can we bring
the tractor he goes no i don't think it
can happen
then my producer my field producer comes
in he's talking to him nope can't happen
nope everybody nope can't happen here
comes ali
what's wrong what's going on i go well
because it rained here we can't get the
vehicles out there as well he goes
he goes okay hold on he goes two minutes
he's over there talking to the gentleman
comes back yeah we're gonna be able to
film there go what how did you make that
happen he's just one of those people
that just you know makes those kinds of
things happen of course the guy got the
tractor he did all the work you know i
don't know i don't know what they said
or what was talked about but
you know he was able to make that happen
and we filmed the whole day where we
were supposed to film it and and it all
worked out and uh
and yeah so very interesting
sean can you further explain
how you got the first two films on
netflix yeah so i think the the first
couple films that we got on there
had to do with the relationship with
warner brothers and them kind of being
the
handling the sales of the films
if that makes sense so
um they're the ones who
and i say they i really again a lot of
this is above my pay grade but um i know
it was a relationship with warner
brothers representing the films to sell
them and they sold it to netflix so
that's how they got it on there and i
believe it was a package deal again it's
above my pay grade but um uh
i believe that's how the first couple of
films got on there and and of course
then the relationship builds and then we
got a couple more on there and that went
really well for us and then you know now
we've got the newest one california
christmas that just came out so i think
we have
um
it's not just my four films with the
same company with esx and ali's ally's
company i think we now have seven films
on there
on netflix so it's been a the
relationship obviously through warner
brothers has built and it's been really
really fantastic and sorry how did you
get the first relationship going with
warner brothers and i know that part's
not i have no you have no clue yeah
that's that's uh that's all ali right
that's his relationship so i don't know
how that all started
right
you've been a director for hire on all
four movies that have gone to netflix
were you competing with other directors
at that time for the job um
i do know um
yes i think there's always been other
directors in consideration
a few of them know i think we just from
the get-go we knew that i was going to
do it and that's because we had already
established that relationship
um but yes there was other
i guess because american fighter was the
first film i directed with them and
there was other directors being
considered uh but that one hasn't come
out yet that one's not on netflix yet
that one is released in uh again in
march
um so that one i knew i definitely was
competing
uh
and there's always there is also that
alex arena rubella who has directed a
bunch of movies with them so it's like
are you gonna direct this when you're
gonna direct you know and we also have
brett headland who has been the editor
on all of our films he also directed a
film for esx called the stand-up packs
and county uh which i helped develop
that script um
but he ended up directing it
because i was directing
wheels of fortune
so i think yeah there's those things and
and certain ones uh yes there's other
uh in consideration and then other ones
it's been
you know hey
we love what you do we want you you know
we think you could tell the story really
well and so i just get offered it
but certainly in the beginning there was
definitely more of that
considering other directors for the
projects
did you personally meet with anybody at
netflix did you go to netflix
no you haven't okay no yeah i haven't
had any i have met with people from
netflix before but not for these movies
um
uh again uh
being the director i'm not the producers
of them i'm not i don't have i am very
uh involved in the post-production
process
from everything editing
visual effects sound design
adr
score i i
have my fingers in every single part of
that uh
but
in making sure that
the deliverables get done but
beyond that
like i said it's kind of above my pay
grade and
um i'm not involved on that level now if
it'd be something that i produced then
that might be
more the case and i have had those
conversations with
films that are
i have personally produced you know that
are through my stuff but but um
uh i did have a movie long ago on
netflix but it was when there were still
dvds that they would send to your house
um
so i remember those days yeah
it's exciting to check the mail
how much involvement does netflix have
during production i know you said with
california christmas yeah this is our
first this is our first um uh
uh netflix original so yeah there is a
certain involvement and again warner
brothers uh there are also those
relationships there um kind of
overseeing making sure everything's
going good and and all that i think
because of
when we filmed this we were one of the
first films
after
this pandemic has started to come back
and film there was tv shows some
docu-series that had been going
but we were one of the first film film
productions to go back in so i think
there's
uh because of those reasons uh it's
maybe a different experience than it
would have been
prior to this
so there's not a whole bunch of people
that just randomly come into sets like
everything is very small controlled
there was some you know
zoom sessions in those kinds of things
from from more of the executives uh
you know in that regard but esx was in
charge of producing the product but yes
from script levels to overseeing sending
clips sending data you know whatever it
is their involvement is that way but not
um coming to set and and uh overseeing
it in that respect at least not on this
again like i said i think because of um
uh
just the current uh world affairs that
that uh
um
it was more from afar you know what i
mean
sure but so you were sending them
dailies i don't know those dailies or
like certain scenes cut together scenes
here that show you a sample you know
those kinds of things um but the way
that we do dailies now it's all digital
it's all up on there so again i'm not
sure what sent to who because i'm so
razor focused on filming and getting the
stuff done
um but very likely it could have been
sent to them to review yeah and they
reviewed the script and gave you notes
yes yeah yeah all that stuff was uh of
course they have to have uh approval on
all that kind of stuff
sean forgive me for asking this but the
timeline can we just go over that one
more time for these movies because it
sounds like it's happened so fast yeah
this year has been very interesting
again i think i think because people are
so starving for content it's why so many
of my projects
came out but roped in lady driver kind
of came out at the same time on netflix
and so those were already out
then
we were already in development and and
working on a california christmas before
wheels of fortune came out so we're
actually on set filming a california
christmas oh i'm sorry actually was
after a california christmas stopped
filming when uh um i was on a different
television a different
project when uh wheels of fortune came
out um and
so yeah so it was had a couple of them
on there
we
i don't remember if that i think the
deal was in place when we started
filming california christmas four wheels
a fortune to come out
um but it didn't come out until after we
were done filming it and then
you know the california christmas is the
one we had the clearest like date of
when where it was going to release
because it's holiday movie we knew
december they wanted it to come out in
early december
to play through for the holidays so
but
on like wheels of fortune we didn't know
what the date exactly would be when when
netflix would want to drop it when they
want to release it obviously i'm sure
they have specific
you know reasons for when they want to
to release uh movies um but i do believe
we had the deal for for
wheels of fortune
while you know before we started filming
uh california christmas if i'm not
mistaken again
a lot of this stuff is i i don't get to
deal with it i don't get the inside
information on that but
um
but yeah uh
so i had two films already but also esx
i believe already had
four films
on uh
on netflix already released before we
started doing the california christmas
project
and that just came out today yeah not
today
when was the production for california
christmas so we started filming um i'm
trying to remember the exact date but it
was in july
of 2020 july of 2020 yeah so it was a
very quick turnaround from filming to
release
um
uh it was it was uh
we were working 24 7 to try and get it
finished through post and delivered
because we had to deliver in i think
late october
um was was the requirement for delivery
if it was gonna air in in december
so
um
uh it was a very very fast turnaround so
but yeah we started filming in in
january
and uh of course we had to get
um everything approved through sag and
all of that with the coveted protocols
and and all of that
and assuming it was filmed in california
correct yes it was filmed in california
yeah yeah yeah what were the protocols
oh sorry oh yeah i was just gonna say up
in northern california petaluma and
sonoma and those surrounding areas is
where we filmed it was beautiful i felt
so lucky and blessed that number one i
was getting to work during this time
because there's so many people who can't
work
and that was certainly the case before i
got to film this i hadn't been able to
do any physical production obviously for
months and months oh really sorry to
interrupt but you sat you were at home
probably yeah i was able to do some
other work and i had post work to do and
things like that so
i still was keeping myself busy but um
yeah not not going and physically
filming anything
so i felt very lucky to be able to do
that and yes we had to have a very
extensive plan number one just to show
to sag and daniel esperante who was one
of the producers on it he put together
this very detailed highly detailed plan
of how we would shoot it how we would
keep everybody safe
and a very impressive plan that he put
together
and because the movie is a little bit
more self-contained it focuses on these
two actors who happen to be married in
real life that helped with you know
certainly getting things approved when
they got approved because we were
like i mentioned before one of the first
features to
to film
um uh
since this whole thing kind of started
since you know shutdowns happened and so
um
uh but yeah it was very interesting it
was a whole different world uh
as far as filming goes um with the covid
protocols number one we were tested like
every other day
um on the onset the good old nose swabs
and
we had more medics on set
um
and also
were temperature checked when we arrived
we were temperature checked before we
left every night
just highly diligent we wore face masks
of course
if we were
in close proximity with the actors we'd
also have the shields so we'd have mask
and shield on
and to that effect
nobody was really allowed to go
get close to the actors while they were
on set other than the camera the the
camera operators and or dp and myself
the director and maybe the ad first ad
were really the only people that could
get in close proximity with the actors
when they didn't have their masks on so
we had to follow those rules
there was also zones
so
you know only a certain amount of people
total could be in any zone at one given
time
so obviously set itself or base camp
would be the hottest zone that's where
the most people would be but we tried to
keep that all separate and on top of all
of this we had a
coveted officer so we had somebody on
set who was overseeing this stuff and
making sure we were keeping socially
distant
um and that we had our masks up they
don't fall down over our nose and you
know you got a bunch of people with
their noses out he was he's on it
matt a wonderful gentleman who was our
covet officer
um he was overseeing all of that and
making sure
uh that we were following all the rules
and um and he actually did it in a very
pleasant way it's not like he's yelling
at people hey your mask is down no he's
very very kind about it but he's very
diligent as well he's on top of it i
mean you really you know um and then
uh
the other thing that i forgot to mention
is when the actors are on set no none of
the other departments can come and work
with them on set even including wardrobe
and makeup
they would have to leave set first to be
able to be checked like outside things
like that as well like when we're
indoors
they have to have all the doors open
you know it's like all of those things
uh
to be um very diligent with that stuff
and then like let's say we need to
adjust a light
well the actors would have to step
offset first be cleared then the
electricians can come in the the uh and
grip department can come in and they can
fix a light or whatever but the really
cool thing that brad rushing our dp
thought about in all of this and i
thought it was genius was they
he decided
to try and light from outside as much as
possible
so bringing in light sources from
outside whether it's backlighting the
actor from like you know it's sunlight
or artificial sunlight coming through a
window or however it was designed he
tried to design a lot of it
coming from outside and
the lights that were inside were remote
so
we had our
gaffers in our lighting department they
could adjust everything like on ipads
and things like that they were able to
dim and do different things they were
able to do a lot without needing to
physically go on set and have to remove
the actors because that of course all
takes extra time
so i thought that was pretty genius to
to approach it that way
um and help us keep our keep our
schedules you know
did did you notice that you would tend
to shoot outside more or no i was just
wondering if that was part of that was
part of the design yeah we did think
about that early on with these protocols
try and limit the amount of scenes that
need to be shot indoors
and again
you know trying to keep it more open
space and when we did go into like a
bedroom or something like that the crew
became very minimal so uh again with the
covet officer we worked with him to
figure out well how many people can be
upstairs safely and it wasn't about like
how many people you know can we get in
we want to get in as many as we can
there's literally about like what is a
real safe you know like what's the real
number can we only have five people up
here you can have two people in that
room and you can have three people in
this room you know what i mean so we
kind of became that dance and everybody
else has to stay downstairs or outside
you know so it was that thing so there
was a lot of
things to juggle that you don't normally
have to
yes they add time the testing adds time
to your like actually takes away time
from your shoot day
um so you have to account for all of
those things but what i will say is it
sounds daunting it sounds like oh this
isn't gonna work
uh but
what i will say is that the the crew and
the new people the the the people
dealing with the covet testing and all
of that
we all got into a rhythm you know first
couple days obviously it's rougher but
we all got into a rhythm and by the end
we were all
firing on all cylinders and you know
came everybody came and got their tests
that you know it just
just you know we came together and we
made it happen um
and uh and everybody worked really hard
you had to work hard because the other
the other thing about it is we had less
crew
because you can't have too many people
so that can put strain on the different
departments like now they have one less
or two less people than they normally
have
so
again luckily we have a team of people
that really aren't afraid of hard work
and they put in the hard work and they
all deserve
all the accolades they can get because
they really do put in
a
tremendous amount of work and that's why
i keep working with the same team i
think because we share that common goal
of you know all trying to make something
as good as we can especially whether
it's limited resources or time or
um but they all just work really really
hard and and uh
i think we're able to accomplish really
great things uh even in the
um
you know
constraints of working during this time
is the covet officer someone you're
hiring
off mandy or one of these sites or is
this someone from the state
that's a great question i
not qualified to answer i don't know um
producers they handled all of that
it is definitely somebody who's
certified within that you know i don't
even know all the certifications but
they're
[Music]
yeah again i don't really know but i
know that they are very they're
certified they're they're up with all
the testing like the latest like but
when we were filming the tests were
changing
and we had always the latest and
greatest the best or whatever it was
we started when we first showed up we
were doing blood tests and then it
became uh
we were doing the finger prick stuff at
the beginning and then that morphed into
just doing the nose swabs and then there
was different levels of nose swabs and
you know like it was very interesting
but they're always at the like forefront
of whatever it is that's going to be the
best have the highest accuracy you know
all those things
um and uh
yeah it was very very interesting and
and uh that whole team so not just
himself but there's a whole team behind
it they all were wonderful and and
obviously
uh their job was to try and keep us safe
um and you know
luckily they did
what about crew feed how is that done
because you know normally it's going to
be like a buffet style that that all
changed too yeah so uh everything is
kind of individually packaged
so and we have caterers and stuff like
that that that
craft services was very definitely very
different so everything has to be
individually wrapped uh you're not you
can't go through and thumb through and
touch a bunch of stuff you have to
figure out what you're gonna choose that
bag of fritos now that you touch that
bag at your bag you know that kind of
thing
um but the probably the biggest bummer
is like i always like to have like fresh
fruit and stuff like that i can't really
do that um
with these protocols so unfortunately
unless you brought it your own in your
own bag you know which i did i brought
bananas and apples of myself
um
but uh
yeah that was very different and again
the lunches are very different you could
only have
everybody was spaced out like this you
know the seating area can't have
everybody bunched in and always outside
basically
um
and um
but yeah the the lunches uh
the meals were all just kind of like in
their own little
kind of package you know individual
portions and packaged and
it was fine it you know it was uh
just became you know kind of standard
after the first week everybody was used
to it
what was the shooting schedule uh so the
shooting schedule was um
uh we usually do like five on two off
type of thing and i think we had one six
day
uh
maybe we had two
really it was it was a pretty short
schedule that's the other
i think reason why we got approved so
early on is it's a limited amount of
days so that's another thing that they
were looking for like you know
what's the shortest amount of time you
can film this in to to limit uh you know
uh you know risk of somebody getting
infected
so um i think we had about 15 days uh
for this shoot
all in like all together which is not a
lot of time
to film a movie but again like i said we
have a great crew that helps us
um
accomplish those goals
what was the last day of shooting and
then i'm not sure again what the day for
deliverables was i think in october how
much time i should have to look when the
when the last day of shooting was um
i think we were just about um
just rolled over into august or just
right before
um
august i can't remember exactly the date
but yeah from that time to getting it
delivered you know was was
we usually have twice that amount of
time to get it done however many months
that is what is that uh basically the
end of october is when we had to deliver
um if my memory is serving me correctly
and
so not only so the good thing was that
the editor had started the process while
we were filming so as we were still
filming as they got footage delivered to
them on hard drives through the mail
um or couriers
they would get the footage uh brett
hedland was the the editor he would get
it and then process it and then start
cutting the scenes
um that was all happening you know it's
offset by obviously a few days
um but then once he gets rolling he's
just you know getting the new footage
and continuing to try and put the pieces
together
and by the time we finished shooting it
wasn't far after that that we had the
first rough cut
um
and so and then i
once i was finished filming i got to
look at the cuts and start and we break
it up in reels so i started reviewing
the reels giving my notes figuring out
what tweaks we can do or if we're
missing a piece you know how we're going
to solve that and
um
so from the editing just getting the the
picture cut then to the sound design to
the score i mean uh
jamie christopherson who did our score
he had such a small amount of time to do
the score i was blown away with the
speed at which he was able to do it and
we had several original songs in there
that he produced
along with caitlyn epperly who is in the
movie but she also sings several
original songs for it and
while we were filming
he had to be helping create those like
rough versions for her to perform
and lip-sync live to
uh while we were filming it but that
meant those songs had to be done
and so
that whole decision that we're going to
do these original songs and
you know from that time to filming
those actual scenes was so short amount
of time i was blown away he was able to
do it and of course they were rough
versions of the song but they still
sounded fantastic and of course they
went in they did they even re-recorded
some of the vocals and did things after
the fact but to to get that and we had
to have her go and record her audio for
it and so is this this pretty amazing
dance that happened but but it all
worked out beautifully and
then getting people in adr which was
really interesting because
um we couldn't bring everybody in like
like even for myself i didn't go into
the studio for the adr
i did it from home and so did a lot of
our actors they didn't go to the studio
either they were
either abroad or
some of them were in their hotel rooms
doing adr for us you know we'd either
send a microphone or or you know somehow
get it that way
and uh
it was really really interesting i'd
never experienced anything like that but
from from doing it like that all remote
to even the color correction sessions
remotely all doing it over zoom and now
we've all got a much shorter time to do
it it was uh
incredibly challenging but again
everybody just rose to the challenge and
i think that's a lot of of
you know the positive stories out of
2020 that i've seen as people rising to
challenges and it's really to me it's
inspirational obviously i try and look
at the glass half full versus empty
that's just my personality but
um i really have seen some amazing
things come out of this year of such
tragedy and obviously so many uh
hardships and so much that has gone
wrong in this year i've seen how people
have risen to that challenge and just
it's been inspirational in that respect
you think it reminds you of of how you
do things because i could see you always
wanting to problem solve yeah and fix it
and yeah and being successful at that
yeah i think there's probably at some
level there there is me seeing
uh
you know people maybe problem solve in
in the way that makes sense to me so
maybe maybe that's what uh
uh
attracts me to to to seeing that but um
uh
yeah i certainly think my uh again i go
back to my martial arts i think
martial arts itself at least what i have
been able to study and the teachers that
i've been lucky enough to to train under
is
it's all about problem solving
so it that's 100 of what it is
um
you know whether you're fighting an
opponent or not or nothing
confrontational because martial arts
again from what the way i've been taught
is it goes much beyond combat there
there is that aspect of it there is
self-defense there is
the sport element of it but beyond that
it's it's kind of philosophy and problem
solving and it helps you in all walks of
life and i think it certainly has helped
me in filmmaking
sean how do you feel about you filmed
this movie in july of 2020
it's now
mid-december 2020 and today it's the
first day it's on netflix um i have to
say it's actually a really good feeling
um
because a lot of times in filmmaking
as you guys probably well know
it can take a long time from inception
to
to release uh in some cases years and
that's certainly been the case uh for a
lot of my movies um some of them are
three plus years before they end up uh
coming out and even big blockbuster
movies they have similar tales some of
them are three plus years um other
movies kind of get shelved for a while
it could be five years before they come
out
so to have something
that you work on within the same year
and i mean even like basically less than
six months
uh kind of go from inception to release
it feels great
it's really nice to see something uh
and and hopefully get a good response
with
just today it's released but i've
already gotten
really really nice and sweet responses
and and
that's just a an amazing feeling and
a feeling that i hope
any creator gets to experience at some
point um
because i also remember every
inch of the set and every second every
minute of of that production because
it's still so fresh in my brain
and
to go from that to
seeing people's reactions to it this
quickly it's a it's a
it's kind of you know endorphin inducing
feeling it feels really wonderful i had
a great morning waking up to getting
some of those messages and
um with some of the other movies it's
been like three years
it's really hard to remember
you know i remember certain moments but
it's obviously not the same thing it's
it's been a long time uh since uh
you know working on those projects
as a director does netflix pay you
residuals
no
and i don't know if that's true for for
every film of course um
but at least at the level i'm at and and
with these films no there's no residuals
um
for that and i don't know if that's the
same for actors so i think actors with
sag and all of that obviously there's a
much different uh
probably uh deal there trying to
remember um
because there was there was um
negotiations for streaming at some point
i'm trying to i'm bad with keeping up on
all the latest uh
information with that um
but for myself no
if a group of young filmmakers came to
you and said they wanted to make movies
only for netflix
what would you advise them in terms of
story production
budget um
yeah for netflix that's interesting
because it's kind of this ever moving
thing so
in in what trends on there
i would say that netflix
at least in my experience or my
perception of it is it is
a little bit more
kind of an algorithm-based thing
you know what i'm saying like it's it's
uh almost like a youtube but not i mean
not the same as youtube but but very
much like what
uh
attracts viewership and uh and things
like that is a little bit more
it is constantly changing
so that's a hard one to to figure out i
think
um
netflix also does things on
all spectrums i mean they have
movies that are made at a couple million
they have movies that are made at 100
million so it's really hard to kind of
pinpoint
exactly
what to say would work to help you get
get it sold onto netflix
other than just
you know try and make stories that
uh
uh
resonate with with an audience
obviously try and make it the it's got
to be of a certain standard certain
quality
so i think those are goals to shoot for
um
but
yeah that's a tough one to say i think
there's probably
uh
the two spectrums of of budget levels
um you've got the ones that you probably
want to keep you know under a certain
amount because then then the sale to
netflix makes sense
because if you make it for too much
you're never going to get that amount
back if that makes sense
but then on the flip side if you've got
you know big name actors in it
you know whoever that might be a will
smith or something then obviously those
numbers completely change so you could
make a 50 million movie and still sell
it and it would make sense on netflix
but again i think a lot of those are
more of the netflix originals as well
that they're willing to put in that kind
of
that kind of a commitment
for a big big movie like that
i don't really see them going after the
you know more uh low low budget stuff
like the
the sub 1 million dollar films but again
i could be wrong because i just don't
know all the inner inner workings of it
um
but uh they definitely also have
parameters in place for
uh your gear so i'd say first and
foremost if that's really your goal
probably the best advice i could say was
find out the specs that they require
because they actually do really require
certain specs like it i believe it has
to be shot in 4k
minimum
and they literally have gear approved
they have a gear approved list for
netflix like what you can film on what
cameras they approve
and things like that so they actually do
have some technical aspects that you
could
kind of
lack of a better word screw yourself out
of ever getting a netflix deal if you
don't meet certain parameters
again i don't know exactly what all
those are and they do change
but
um i do know that there are
certain like uh
i believe the black magic pocket cameras
are actually approved for netflix so
something on that level which is still
affordable uh
and and uh
you know to a certain degree are still
at enough quality level to be approved
by netflix i believe again don't quote
me on any of this but um
but there are certain ones that aren't
for whatever reason it doesn't meet the
specs
maybe the color space isn't deep enough
doesn't have enough bits or whatever
so that would be the starting point like
make sure you check with that kind of
stuff and and and make your goals of
filming it to meet those certain
parameters
um
other than that i think they
uh
they obviously um
you know uh stream such a wide variety
of things you can see i've got very kind
of
family-friendly pg movies in lady driver
and roped that actually were really
successful on netflix they trended they
were on the popular lists roped i think
climbed as high as like 22
on like most popular film on netflix uh
and it's it's a very much uh
pg family friendly and then you have the
opposite end of the spectrum where
you've got the you know uh
very gritty dark you know the stranger
things and those kinds of shows that are
extremely successful so i think they
really are open to a variety of uh
genres and styles of filmmaking so it's
really hard to pinpoint you know what
would work and what wouldn't work on
there um
but obviously
check the specs that's where i'd start
and then make a good story
and uh and
be as creative and get the best quality
that you can
and are those specs available to the
public on their website or so
you know where i've read about it as has
been more in like the
um
like film gear uh
like websites and publications like that
um i have seen like hey this camera is
actually you know meets the
meets
you know netflix approved specs
i personally never have seen a sheet or
whatever that says what those specs are
but um and i've never searched it up but
i have read about it like i said in
in uh
those you know like
4kshooter.com or something like that you
know one of those uh one of those
websites uh
um i've read about uh the different
cameras and if they meet the spec like
this red komodo that just came out it
got netflix approved
so you can use this new red camera
that's uh it's kind of a much smaller
red and it uh i believe it shoots 6k
um so it doesn't do the 8k that the
newer reds or the other reds are doing
now like we shot
we filmed
california christmas on
a red geminis that are
8k um
and we we shot uh
with some vintage lenses though we had
these vintage anamorphic cowas that we
shot on
on uh on this 8k new camera i always i
actually really love
trying to meld old and new that's
something that really kind of excites me
um even to the point that uh which i
have been known to search you know ebay
for some vintage style lenses that might
not fit on my cameras but i will figure
out a way to adapt them
um
even with metal files out in the garage
i'm shaving down you know mounting parts
to make them fit together and i love
experimenting with that kind of stuff
so anytime i get that opportunity i do
it this was the second film that i
took really like vintage uh anamorphic
style lenses and put them match them
with the with the newer cameras and
i love the results i think it's uh just
makes for really interesting imagery and
um
and i just love anamorphic as well if i
had a choice i would film everything on
anamorphic just a quality to it that
that excites me
so you feel the older lenses are are
somehow
lengthened to a better story and forgive
me i i don't know
it's like more character so the lens the
lens itself uh the older lenses tend to
have more character which can be
described in like you know maybe the the
edges blur a little bit differently or
um
certainly lens flares are very different
uh especially with anamorphic um and
there's some wonderful new anamorphic
lenses i've actually filmed with them as
well and they looked beautiful
but
i just happen to really love the
characteristics the way it bends light
is slightly differently
slightly different or
again the way it pulls focus maybe to
the center because the edges or maybe
the the the sharpness starts to
dissipate towards the edges which can
it in one respect could be a little bit
maybe scary for a filmmaker going oh i
want to make sure the shot's in focus
but if you understand that and know that
going in you know where the lens might
be softer and so you're not going to
frame it that way to where it would be
an issue or you make sure you're paying
attention like oh the top of their heads
may be getting a little too blurry so
you reframe a little bit to make sure
they're in the sweet spot of the lens a
lot of the older lenses have sweet spots
so you got to kind of understand and
know that or else you could get yourself
in trouble where the people are out of
focus but
um
but i just love the characteristics of
it and and when you look at
certainly the filmmakers that influenced
me the most they almost always have shot
on anamorphic and some of those that
very same models that i've used from the
cowas and the hawks and uh and uh even
some of the ingenues um
you know some spielberg's and the
and the
you know uh
uh
kubricks and all that use those same
same kind of uh
lenses so
um
that was always kind of a dream of mine
was to to be able to shoot on those
someday and then it's come to fruition
on a couple projects i've gotten to to
use some of those vintage uh
lenses which was
exciting for me because i'm kind of a
camera nerd that way i really geek out
on all the different technology and i
love new technology but i also love the
old stuff too so again that's where it
comes back to me loving to
figure out a way to marry the two
together um and
that's just always a
a kind of
exciting challenge to me
and if you buy those lenses on ebay do
you then later sell them again
um not really no i kind of keep them you
know i have some old russian uh lenses
that just do some really cool uh bouquet
or boca the way it uh
kind of almost a circular blur to them
uh those are really cool i've used those
actually i used one of those on
california christmas for a scene
um
to me they're always like they're tools
that you can use for a certain situation
it might be really perfect for that
moment
and uh so i've got those i've got i just
i actually just adapted a a 70s ingenue
zoom lens fratello it was a television
lens
and uh it's a gorgeous lens and i got it
for like 150 bucks on ebay and that lens
probably when it came out was 50 60 000
but
uh
you couldn't really use it on a modern
camera especially the the mounting
wouldn't work
and so what i discovered i had to modify
the mount on it in order to get it to
work with another adapter that would
then work on the i have a blackmagic uh
pocket camera so to get it to even fit
on there i had to modify the the rear
mounting element on it which i took it
off the lens and kind of did everything
i needed to do with it to make it fit
and then the other thing about those
lenses and probably why you could get
them
i think other people are discovering
this now because i've seen the price of
them go up
you're giving away your secrets
they're now like 600 ish in that range
that i've been seeing
but the lens itself is a eight
millimeter to 112 millimeter zoom which
is a pretty decent zoom but
it's
the size of of
the uh the back glass
is too small for a modern camera
like a like a black magic
what happens when you put that lens on
there you have a
crazy vignette so you basically see the
circle of the back element so that
you're only seeing and everything else
is black you know and you've got this
little circle
and that's the reason why most
people wouldn't buy that lens
and you can get them for the price that
you can get them but on certain versions
of those lenses they had built-in
doublers
so basically there's a magnifier on the
back end of the lens that you can flip
and what the purpose of it originally
was for those lenses is it made them
twice the focal length so
you could then
you know on the just a flip of a switch
you could double your focal length you
could go from a 100 to a 200 millimeter
zoom and you know there's all sorts of
cool things you can do with that what i
discovered
is
that you could take that same lens
and
put the doubler on it
and now it fills the full frame of my
camera
so i don't have an 8 to 112 millimeter i
actually have a 14 to 220 millimeter
lens which is still a great focal length
for me to have on my camera i mean
that's as wide as i'll ever need it and
that's almost as tight as i'll ever need
it and so that was the experiment of
wanting to make that lens work and
figure out how to adapt it to get it to
work on my camera and
it worked it's it's really pretty
incredible uh and in fact the black
magic
is there's a crop factor or like a
on that so
effectively what my camera is is i think
it's a 22 millimeter to 400 and like
450 millimeter zoom and it looks
beautiful i did a bunch of test footage
with it and
again it has those old characteristics
that i love
looks like you know you're shooting
something in the 60s or 70s
um
and
you know cost me 150 bucks so there you
go
um and i will use it on a project uh i
guarantee somewhere somehow i'll end up
using that lens
um for something
so you keep them safely stored away yeah
yeah and i bring it with me on my
project so
um yeah so it was so interesting about
that anjanu is that it's a it's a
french-made lens
and
the style of a
mount that it had was i think it was
called the b3 like a bayonet 3. and
japanese lenses made it you know
american all that stuff they all had
this b3 mount well
i was able to find
online b3 adapters to micro four thirds
so great
here we go i can i can just buy this
adapter and it'll work no it didn't work
there was
a piece on that back element
that
on that back mount element on the ingenu
that was several millimeters deeper than
it was on like the canons of the same
era or the other ones that that adapter
would work on did not work on mine so i
looked i had to really like break it
down like what is stopping this adapter
from mounting correctly i figured out
which pieces it was and then i'm like
okay
so how do i
get this this piece
luckily it was aluminum so it was fairly
soft that mounting piece so i was able
to take metal files like i said get it
down to the right level which actually
took a long time longer than i was
expecting and then i went with you know
some finer uh sanding materials and and
got it to be smooth and then i like you
know
finished it so that it was wouldn't
affect the adapter at all and then it
worked mounted on there and and i didn't
know if that would change
your rear focus element i was a little
bit worried that maybe that would affect
it to where this adapter is made for a
certain thing and your back glass needs
to be a certain distance from your
sensor in order for it to work so i
wasn't sure by filing this piece down if
i would was a risk i was like i could be
possibly
ruining this at this mount for my lens
and it might not it might not work
because it'll just be a few millimeters
different
but luckily
it actually worked right out of the gate
as soon as i mounted it i was able to
focus all the way through and those old
the other cool thing about those old
lenses is they have a back element
adjuster so it's basically like a screw
a nut that you undo and you can then
move and it moves the distance from that
back glass so you can really dial it in
you can dial them in to to be
i'm trying to remember the term but it's
basically at your widest focal distance
you're in focus and when you zoom in
through the whole thing you're in focus
and only certain lenses can do that and
new lenses don't a lot of them don't do
that or they're like sixty thousand
dollars like i said that lens will do
this but your two thousand dollar canon
can't do that you know what i mean so
having this lens that has that ability
is pretty darn cool
um and i was able to dial that all in i
was i was i was actually really
surprised that one worked
to be honest but
um
i then bought two more of that style
lenses to try and experiment one i
failed one i can't get it to adapt
correctly
but the other one i was it was a canon
one was a fujinon i couldn't get the
fujinon to work right
but the canon i was able to to get
to work um
and i just used that one on a commercial
shoot not that long ago
and it worked great
and again that was a similar focal
length so right now it's like a 28 to
480 millimeter zoom
if you want to know those are the old
eng lenses
okay so those are old like uh
you know 60s 70s 80s really like 70s is
probably where most of these are from um
but they're eng lenses uh so like um
beretta and shows like that like yeah
yeah yeah and uh um
you can probably find that most of them
are like fujinon and canon like on ebay
and stuff and they're um
the i'm trying to think if it's there
the two-thirds inch eng lenses is what
i'm talking about and they need to have
that
built-in doubler so it's like a two
times
focal length piece on it and they look
really funky they come off the back of
the lines that's how you can usually
tell they're on there but in the
description always you know make sure
you get one because if you get one that
doesn't have that doubler and you try
and put it on a modern camera most of
them
um
it will
again like i said you'll just have that
big vignette uh where you know it's not
really usable um but once you have that
the doubler that's built in onto them
that
you know you can never use it really
without it on so you just have to live
with this is my new focal length is is
the double
of this lens you know what i mean so
because you said it gets too close to
the sensor
it's not that it gets too close to the
sensor it's just that the back element
is too small to cover the full width of
your sensor
so
but what happens is when that with those
built-in doublers is it's a piece of
glass that basically
if this is the back of the lens if this
is your piece of glass this this
magnifier comes on top of it and it is
bigger than that piece and that
magnifica magnification
uh
it creates the image to be big enough to
cover your your whole lens or your whole
i'm sorry sensor
so you don't you no longer have those
vignette on your on your thing
so um yeah it's pretty cool pretty cool
little little uh trick i'm not the only
one who's discovered it either there's
there's other people uh who have who
have experimented with it but definitely
um it's not like a common thing but
i always love that stuff like i said
i've taken old uh still camera lenses
i've got some zeiss lenses from the from
the 50s and 60s that i've adapted
from
uh
exact amounts which is a really
interesting mount
luckily i was able to find some people
that have made pieces to to that can
adapt that to like cannon mount
and
and then i take the cannon mount and
adapt that to the micro four thirds or
you know whatever the the different
challenges are
uh or different camera that we might be
putting it on
um but i've gotten some great uh
those the old zeiss's are usually at
least a couple hundred uh dollars but
to me if you can find a clean one that
doesn't have
uh you know a bunch of scratches on the
lens or a bunch of fungus on the lens
they're still they're really great
pieces of glass
i have a 25 millimeter
zeiss
carl zeiss lens from the 50s that's
incredible it's
tack sharp still today and just a really
really nice piece of glass that i got
for a couple hundred dollars where
anything modern would cost you several
thousand at least for that same focal
length and and uh quality
how do you protect it from fungus do you
keep it away from moisture yeah that you
know the funny thing about fungus is
that it actually
uh
it's hard to to you know say why some
lenses get it and some don't but it is
probably it has to do with moisture and
and how sealed they are
most of the time though fungus really
won't affect your image too much it
affects how light comes in to the lens
and will like bend uh
like like uh kind of the flares
so sometimes even a little fungus is
kind of cool on an old lens in my
opinion
now if it's right in the dead center of
your lens maybe that then becomes
annoying but if it's just around the
edges again it could give you some of
those qualities that i actually even
like
so i won't necessarily turn down a lens
on ebay if it's got a little fungus on
it just depends on where it is
but things like scratches and things
that really will kind of affect the
image then obviously you got to stay
away from that but
yeah i mean it depends on what project
you're doing if you need something super
clean and you want it to look you know
tack sharp like that then those lenses
won't be for you but
if you're trying to do something that
has a little bit more of that style to
it then
i say go for it experiment with it and
and see what you can do because uh
you know to me that's that's what will
set your project apart make it make it
feel a little different you know
how would you know if a lens has fungus
on it if you're seeing it on some site
that's selling well i always ask those
questions and most people uh that i've
discovered they will they'll list what's
wrong with the lens and stuff like that
so most of them will say
no you know clean glass no scratches
fungus free they'll say something like
that or they'll talk about the blades
the blades aren't oily because a lot of
times the lenses if the
like they'll have like a
a leak in the the it'll affect how the
uh shutter uh and the aperture works
not the shutter but the the aperture
itself so
they'll list like what's you know
you know you just have to read the
details then ask questions if you you
know and i'll ask that a lot of times
i'll ask you know
you know is it does it have this or does
it have that to clarify and again like i
said sometimes i might be okay with it
they go is there fungus is it like all
over the the lens or is it like just on
the edges you know
and uh
and i might still buy it if it has it if
it if that's what i'm going for you know
in that moment and if the price is right
you know
sean i'm hoping we can go to page one of
your script for a california christmas
and i'm curious what you like about the
opening scene of the movie which is page
one of course
yeah so uh the opening is obviously it's
meant to establish
uh joseph's character played by josh
wickard and he's kind of living this
playboy lifestyle big city uh wealthy um
obviously he's got uh
uh someone in bed and uh
you know he's young and he's kind of
using his his uh
obviously his status to uh
kind of live carefree in that way so
basically the point of it is to set up
his character
and and
for his arc throughout the story because
obviously he needs to grow
he's not the best of guys at this point
um
so it's really i think it helps
illustrate that point it sets up who he
is and the journey he's gonna have to go
on whether he likes it or not is
basically is is the idea obviously you
won't know all of that while seeing this
first scene but it sets it up of who
he is and where he is at at this point
in his life
and he's not a total jerk he offers to
buy the woman room service so you got to
give him some props but
so yeah yeah
again i think
those little details is that we we don't
want people to just completely hate him
right off the bat right
and we did have some other things early
in early versions and stuff that we're
like yeah that might make him too much
of a jerk you know uh certainly
there's an argument there that he's
still a jerk but you know what i'm
saying like
he has to have some underlying
qualities and redeemable pieces that
that you want to see him go on a journey
of growth and
self-growth and and becoming
hopefully a better person
so before we meet joseph the main
character we have this aerial shot can
we talk about the establishing image yes
the very first shot is kind of coming up
off the off the water and revealing san
francisco which is uh
you know that's where he is and where
his family business is
um so kind of just establishing that
whole the bay area and the big city and
the in the the hustle and bustle of city
life because it is a
uh
obviously stark contrast to the ranch
that he later goes to and ends up
spending a lot of time
and we also did some interesting things
in color there so
the city life has has a little bit
cooler of tones to them and when we go
to the ranch
everything becomes a little bit warmer
and
and
earthier
in the tones so
that's like a little you know kind of
little details that we pay attention to
when we're making it probably most
people will never notice it but
even with that opening shot we wanted
the color palette of it to be feel
cooler in tone
uh versus the later part of the movie
and also too he leaves kind of like one
woman in a hotel room and then as he
leaves he kind of flirts with
a desk clerk or something and yeah you
see her sort of fun not not
unprofessionally but you so it already
sets him up to be sort of this casanova
type correct yes yeah he's definitely
got that air about him and
and uh you get the sense that uh
you know
he doesn't hear know a lot she doesn't
hear no a lot it's that hashtag best
life thing right
he's living his best life but you know
anyways obviously there's more to it
than that and and at his core he's he's
uh
searching for more
sure sure um what do you think the hook
is of the first page that makes people
want to keep reading
it goes beyond just the first page i
guess but the hook of the first page is
is is really the the kind of setting and
the character like for me when i read it
i wanted to know more about him you know
so it's really like
why is he this way like what makes him
uh and especially kind because he's kind
of
outright just
turns the girl down for a second date
like right there
makes you go well that's audacious like
what like what is his story so
hopefully that's the hook that was for
me when i read it because uh i didn't
write this lauren swicker didn't and
when i was sent it
that's what grabbed me right away
and i think she says kind of like i'll
call you or whatever and she says no you
want yeah exactly that little piece
right there i'm like okay
yeah
and and the fact that he can get away
with that i think there's probably
plenty of people go well i wouldn't be
able to get away with that or you know
you know those kinds of things uh
it makes it intriguing and and and of
course
the you see that the relationship
walking through the hotel lobby the
people like him you know and he's he's
got that thing about him his charm is
charisma
um
always makes it more interesting and i
think even in the back of my head i'm
was even initially you know even right
away thinking oh he's gonna have some
lessons to learn you know what i mean
like there's
he's probably gonna have to go on a
journey you know
and sorry he's brought in to be and i
hope this isn't spoiler to be like a
honey plot to kind of like infiltrate
and and
seduce someone that he needs a signature
from so basically his his company and
his mother who runs the company they
haven't been able to get this
the owners of this ranch to sell which
they need to build a shipping facility
uh for their corporation uh their
business and so
his mom decides that
her son basically doesn't really do
anything
you know he's got a title and works at
the company but what does he actually do
so she recognized he has a certain skill
and and it is a younger woman who owns
the ranch and so she says let's put your
actual skills to use go out there and
get this girl to sell you know get this
woman young woman to sell
and so
i think he thinks he's going to be able
to waltz in there and and get his way
and and get the the the yes that he
always hears um and uh
and uh
i can say it doesn't go as as he had
planned sure and his ark
falls
there's some case of missing missing
identity as well uh or misidentity that
that not missing a misidentity that that
happens for him as well in there um
that kind of
starts him down a totally different
journey that that he thought he was
going to be going on
so looking back on it now what mistakes
do you think were there in the first
page or was this the
actual shooting script and there were no
mistakes oh uh well this yeah this is
definitely not the the first version of
the script for sure so
this is this is um
closer to the shooting i can't remember
if what i sent you is the actual
shooting shooting one
and gosh it's hard to remember if if
there was i think there there was more
time taken in in earlier drafts which i
think it took too long to get to those
pieces and it is of course not even just
the first page but but that was part of
it so i think it got more refined and
kind of
picked the moments that actually
mattered to to convey the the message
that we're trying to convey is this
still the opening of the movie yes this
is still the opening of the movie right
so yeah it uh
it stayed and obviously i think it's
important again because we have to
establish
our
our
character's journey you know
his character so joseph and also cali
they both have their journeys um and
they kind of you know their journeys
intersect and that's what they they help
each other on their journey so that's
kind of the
that's the you know uh
age-old kind of love twist there their
their
their journeys intersect and and of
course they need each other to to kind
of
uh complete their journey
the film american fighter you're the
co-writer sean is that right yes i
co-wrote it and directed it oh great
okay
and it has martial arts elements to it
yep oh yeah yep there's martial arts so
definitely drew from some of that
experience and it's interesting because
it takes place in 1981 so it's kind of
pre-mma in that whole thing so it deals
with kind of illegal underground
fighting
so certainly martial arts involved but
there's also this kind of street
fighting brawling
thing that happens as well and and
in wrestling and so it integrates a lot
of different uh
fighting styles if we take a look at the
first page for the screenplay that you
co-wrote american fighter
our protagonist is raza and you see
kind of his life it seems like it jumps
back to different parts can you talk
about that yeah so the main character is
actually ali he
the opening of the film which which i
felt was was important was to kind of
tell this story kind of jumping back and
forth and it opens with him
in kind of the fight of his life the
movie starts with this you see some
images some flashes and pieces of this
fight and where he's kind of going to be
at the lowest point as well
and then we take a step back and the
film is then going to lead up to that
moment again
and the reason for that was it wasn't
originally written that way this was you
know the later and then to the shooting
draft we decided that it was important
to have
show that element right away number one
to kind of it's that big impactful start
like get audiences interested and
curious like wait a minute why is this
happening why are these two people
fighting and there's a huge crowd around
them and and uh
you know what is it all about we see our
hero fall right like right in this the
end of this beginning fight he gets
almost knocked unconscious and so we go
from there to him waking up in his
college dorm room
and uh that's you know several weeks
earlier or months earlier he's worried
about his his family's supposed to be
flying because he's from iran and he's
worried about and this is 1981 so the
setting is
the iraq iran war
had just started
and it was a terrible time in that area
and just
like two years earlier
was the iran hostage crisis that
happened and so in america at that time
it was not a great time to be iranian
and so he had to face those kinds of
issues but so he wakes up this college
dorm room uh he's got a roommate who's a
good friend and but he's really afraid
for his parents he wants
them to make it over
from iran safely to the u.s and so
his roommates kind of assure him that
he's gonna be fine and uh they've got
wrestling practice
and so the idea the concept is he is
there for like a wrestling scholarship
um and that's part of what helped get
him out of iran
uh
iran i should say not iran but iran
helped get him out of iran
because of his wrestling prowess
um
and so
he's now trying to help his parents get
over
because his mom is sick she has cancer
and so he's trying to get her to
to some more western medicine
um and that's kind of what jumps off the
the story so in the first page if i
remember correctly there's is like a
sort of these different flashes so he's
getting beat up then
you see like a happy moment where he's
running and saying mom i'm coming to
america look at the letter or something
there's a flash of the picture of the
ayatollah
and then there's
the mother being hooked up to tubes so
all these like sort of things are coming
at you
yeah that's when he gets uh
knocked unconscious
um he flashes back to his
childhood when he was back in iran
and uh he's kind of flashing to the
moment that he found out
uh that his mother
that something was wrong with his mom
so that's kind of uh that's what's
happening there um he's not running
excited that he's going to to america
what's happening is actually his father
is
telling him he's going to send him there
because he'll be safer oh okay sorry so
he's going to go live with his uncle
um
in america and he's actually
disappointed like he's he's scared about
this prospect of having to leave his
family
um but they you know recognize that he
has the opportunity there he's obviously
really good at wrestling and that can
that's what's creating this opportunity
for him to get out
um of the really bad situation that was
happening at that time
and so it's almost a nightmare of what
he's experiencing um
and that leads him into waking up in his
dorm room
um
and so yes he hears a new news broadcast
you know you see that's
it's maybe a little bit different in the
actual film versus what's on the page
but basically there's news broadcasts
happening talking about the events that
are that are happening during that time
uh and that kind of
crosses with what his father is telling
him about i need to send you to america
and uh
and then him
rushing to see his mother
um
and i always had this like kind of
haunting image of following him kind of
in a you know a slower motion as he's
making his way down this hallway to this
door that's cracked open
and as he
as he pushes the door open he sees his
mother and she looks at him smiling and
as she tries to stand up
to talk to him she collapses and that's
the the terror he's he's uh
uh
having in that moment and it's actually
based on something that really happened
to me so that was that was a moment
directly ripped from my own childhood
and
my mother is still here so i'll preface
it that way but she
had an aneurysm so it wasn't cancer but
it was an aneurysm and she collapsed in
a very similar way and it was that
terrifying you know
and i had my own kind of fevered
nightmares for years and years about it
um
and so that's a little piece of me that
made it into the the script there that's
melded with other kind of uh
memories from ali as well ali afshar
because he produced it and this
character is actually based on him now
this story has some real elements but
other ones are you know we fabricated
for for for the movie but
um the character himself is based on ali
and his because he's also a wrestler and
all of that stuff and he did come over
from iran and uh
and all that have some similar
experiences there so you really see the
stakes are high so it's not just
he's being pulled from his homeland
leaving his family there's government
turmoil his mother is sick so
everything's kind of thrown in that
first page yep all stakes are like you
know what he's dealing with
right there okay yeah okay did page one
did it evolve did it change was it
definitely did
yeah it definitely evolved and at first
we didn't see that fight happening
uh and uh
right away um it did always kind of
start with that dream
so that was there from the beginning but
yeah it evolved there was many many
different drafts of it and we
experimented with different ways to open
it um and ultimately that's what we
settled on um was kind of yeah throwing
all the
all the and i there is a kind of a funny
story to as to why
uh we ended up going that direction and
within the movie because the time it was
it was the summer
um
what was the school year after the
summer that uh
star wars empire strikes back came out
um and
so within that script that was all the
rage at the time like everybody was
talking about especially obviously the
first star wars was such a huge success
and then this follow up with yoda and
everything and the controversial
ending of empire strikes back sorry
spoilers but darth vader is luke's
father
um that's like all anybody talked about
at that time and so we worked that into
the script i'm a huge star wars
nerd myself i love star wars and so
a lot of that
my personality was coming out through
the script in that way too so we have
ali's roommates characters really into
star wars and he can't believe that ali
has never seen star wars so that is a
running joke through the whole script
and he's doing yoda impressions very
terribly by the way but
doing them nonetheless and and uh so i
thought that was a really fun thing to
to help
uh set the tone and time
place that this movie was set
um
but the other thing that i thought about
was
looking at great movies like that like
the original star wars how does it open
it opens with such a bang i mean it's
just right off the bat
action is happening spaceships are
flying overhead lasers are going you
know you just get
all this all the stakes are set right
there
and so that influenced how the opening
pages of our movie
um
happened it was like obviously we don't
have spaceships and all that fun stuff
but we want to
throw it in your face right away like
start it with a bang and hopefully get
the audience hooked right there right
from the first flash you see on screen
and like whoa what's happening oh my
gosh it's a fight you know and oh look
at this kick and this punch and oh he's
oh no he's he's down already you know is
is uh
directly kind of influenced from star
wars uh and like how the rebels
immediately their ship gets captured by
the bad guys and all hope looks lost
right away you know so um yeah
with american fighter are we
establishing i'm sorry is it reza is it
is he is he the main character or not
ali oh sorry for some reason i think
yeah i may have sent you i may have sent
you a a draft that had the wrong name
like okay we did play with it not being
uh ally at one point so that's probably
the draft you got no problem i was
searching for those drafts and i
couldn't find because again on a
different computer three years ago
so i think i must have sent you the
wrong one on accident
in page one of american fighter are we
establishing ali's kind of personality
or we're just more seeing the stakes
that he's against
i think yeah it's more about the stakes
that he's against because in the first
page we don't get to see maybe a ton of
his personality
um but that does come out right kind of
in this in the the subsequent pages you
get to know him a little bit more um
and uh and
comes out in some of the playful banter
with him and his roommate and
and uh but the the story does get very
serious very quick for ali so
unfortunately he doesn't get uh
a lot of lighthearted time uh in this in
this particular film
is this first page still the opening of
the movie
more or less yeah there was some tweaks
that that and some stylistic choices
that we played with but uh it's not
exactly but yeah there's a lot of it is
still there
so what was the log line for american
fighter did you or like if you were
going to do your elevator pitch what was
it sort of oh my gosh it's been so long
fight club meets wrestlers yeah it's
it's it's it's uh uh
it really is it's like
got equal parts rocky and and karate kid
i mean those are
those
it's got a lot of heart
um and and blood sport i don't know how
many people know bloodsport but uh it's
it's kind of an amalgamation of all
those things um but again like i said
the the heart and the reason why he
fights is to try and save his mother so
that's kind of at the core of it um
uh
and that kind of sets it apart from
those movies
in a way
um but yeah it's the it's the journey
for
this character ally like
uh
how far is he willing to go for for love
you know for family and it's a love
story about his there is a love interest
in it and played by the awesome alison
page she's amazing but the the core of
the love story is actually that for his
his mother you know and he's willing to
do anything to help save her um and
including fighting in underground
bare-knuckle brawls putting his you know
life at risk
um
if it means he can
save her because the story is is
actually very tragic his father is
killed um
when they try and leave the country and
it has to deal with the with the the uh
the
events that were going on at that time
so
how many drafts did you have of the
script oh my gosh lots
lots probably too many to count like
official drafts you know we go through
the different colors once we we started
pre-production
um
probably a good
six or seven or something like that
um that's like from initial like
breaking maybe more like five
um
but yeah all in
at least a dozen
yeah
at least probably more